bonjour je me présente je m'appelle
laurent hubert j'ai 42 ans et participe
aujourd'hui au challenge du créateur
pour le prix de l'insertion
j'ai créé mon entreprise il ya tout
juste onze mois donc en novembre de
l'année dernière et je suis de formation
esthéticiens praticiens forme et
bien-être
j'ai ouvert mon entreprise donc
moralement d'esthétique arbio et 100
instituts à saint-cloud team sur la
route du bord de mer
j'ai travaillé pendant 14 années dans le
monde du sport donc
au niveau de l'hôtellerie suite à cela
j'ai travaillé six ans dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique le bien-être et le monde
de l'esthétique également le monde du
spa était 12h était toujours été ma
passion en fait
et donc comme j'ai failli perdre mon
dernier emploi
j'ai saisi cette opportunité pour
justement va concrétiser mon rêve c'est
à dire créer ma propre structure le but
pour moi c'est valoriser les métiers qui
sont généralement occupé par un monde de
femmes donc aujourd'hui mon but c'est
juste la preuve bon ben c'est à dire en
tant que honda je réussis à me faire à
nous faire une place aussi bien dans le
métier aussi bien en ayant la confiance
de mon client